toutes ces toutes ces manifestations que
le peuple soulève quotidiennement
n'était pas là et à 25 ans dont ka se
rajoute à ce problème qui n'est pas
réglée toujours qui est les problèmes
but brute de brutalité policière qui ne
sera jamais réglé
on ne demande pas à ce que est ce qu'il
n'y ait plus de brutalité policière on
demande juste ce qu'il y ait du respect
de la reconnaissance de ces problèmes
pour qu'on puisse les régler c'est tout
ça c'est ajouter aujourd'hui l'époque et
plus beaucoup plus intense que celle de
l'époque on a l'impression qu'on en
n'avait jamais autant parlé qu'on en a
parlé au mois de juin au moins de 2 au
début du mois de juillet ouais mais vous
savez c'est bête à dire mais le film dit
un truc qui d'une phrase qui est très
connu qui dit l'important c'est pas la
chute c'est l'atterrissage
on nous prévenait moi je me souviens que
quand j'avais 20 ans nous prévenait à la
télévision nous disait faites attention
parce que dans trente ans et
l'atterrissage au niveau écologique
il va y avoir des problèmes dans trente
ans on va aller on va si on ne règle pas
maintenant on va avoir des problèmes on
a essayé les régler on a participé à ça
on a peut-être poussé un petit peu
l'échéance mais on est en plein dans
cette dans ces problèmes-là donc
aujourd'hui pour moi le problème est
plus sur la brutalité policière qui est
un problème qui fait qu'ils aient qui
fait partie de la société qui ne sera
jamais réglé encore une fois il est
vraiment sur le sert vraiment de
problème de société
dans sa généralité mais on le voit 25
ans plus tard que on est dans cette
période d'atterrissage et que le sol se
rapproche et on a pour aucun moyen de on
n'a pas de parachute
d'ailleurs c'était la phrase jusqu'ici
tout va bien qui revenait dans le film
vous pensez que jusqu'ici tout va bien
encore non moi j'ai jamais pensé que
jusqu'ici tout allait bien moi je
pensais que je sais c'est évidemment du
sarcasme phrase je pense pas que
jusqu'ici tout va bien enfin si mais
vraiment dans la dans la tête de
quelqu'un qui tombe d'un immeuble de 50
étages silas et de philosophie tout va
bien jusqu'au moment de l'atterrissage
mais je propose et ça sert à rien le
problème c'est que ça sert à rien de
paniquer la chute elle est là elle est
irrémédiable et il faut juste gérer
l'atterrissage donc est-ce qu'on va
réussir à le gérer ou est-ce qu'on va se
laisser complètement aller ça je n'en
sais rien
[Musique]